bạn
[âm nhạc]
Ờ nã chuẩn là
à cần là các bạn hỏi m cái câu trên này
tôi nghĩ là mình sẽ phải có một cái
khung giờ nào đó nhất định hoặc Hoàn
thời gian nào đó nhất định để mà kiểu
trả lời m câu này không các bạn chẳng
biết
à xem cả buổi video chẳng thấy ông phải
trả lời câu hỏi của mình
[âm nhạc]
đấy thì nó lại hơi buồn cười quá vì rõ
ràng là câu hỏi này có thể là từ buổi
trước V trước nữa
ràng là đúng là cũng hơi bị
mất mất cái kiểu tính thần để mà ngồi
livestream như này thì tính ra là chắc
là tôi kểu livestream để tâm sự Chú yếu
chứ chứ còn bây giờ bảo là muốn code vào
khoảng thời gian này trong ngày thì chắc
là lâu lắm mà không Cốt buổi tối kiểu
quen kiểu dạng làm việc ban ngày quen
việc động não ban ngày buổi tối thì tôi
gần như là tôi thư giãn là nhiều ấy gì
nhỉ
Hả mic có vấn đề à
alo alo alo
alo mic không được như như
trước đợ tí
để ý nhớ không để ý Kiểu m
Tôi dùng dùng máy này mang đi dậy nữa n
phải đổi lại tí đợi đợi tôi một tí Đợi
tôi một
tí mic mic chứ
ờ
thì kểu tính là gần đây hơi bị xuống
tinh thần một tí vì livestream giờ gần
như là code là ông mấy ông cũng thấy là
kiểu Nó gần như một buổi để mà trả lời
câu hỏi với tâm sự là nhiều chứ không
phải là chia sẻ cái gì đó hay ho vì gần
như là não tôi vào khoảng thời gian này
nó cũng gọi là để nghỉ hơn cũng kiểu đi
làm cả ngày căng não ấy
thì chưa Đang chưa quen gồng được đấy
Kiểu thế bởi vì ví dụ nhá Hôm qua tôi
vẫn quen ngủ Bây giờ tôi vẫn quen kiểu
ngủ khuya đến tầm 2 3 gi sáng sau đó thì
mà ví dụ sáng ngày hôm qua chẳng hạn tôi
sẽ phải dậy lúc 6:00 sáng để mà đi
dậy kiểu dạy học lúc 7:30 mà Thì 6:00
tôi dậy tôi chuẩn bị mọi
thứ thôi Ngồi nói 8 tiếng ngồi BN 4
tiếng buổi sáng xong rồi nghỉ chưa được
tiếng rưỡi xong rồi lại ng nói TM 4n
tiếng tiếp là tôi cảm thấy là khi đi dạy
học thì tôi phải phải kiểu luôn tỉnh táo
hơn phải luôn kiểu nói chung là mình
phải luôn năng động luôn năng nổ các thứ
chứ mình không thể trầm được đúng không
ạ sinh viên nó sẽ nhận năng lượng từ
mình nên là thành ra là kiểu Tôi không
muốn là mình kiểu trầm gì cả nế Thành An
mình kiểu năng động xôi nổi thành ra khi
khi mà
kiểu những cái lúc đi dậy thế tôi cảm
thấy còn căng hơn cả việc đi làm đi làm
thì mình còn thoải mái linh hoạt được
nhưng mà đi làm thì tôi vẫn cống hiến
tôi vẫn
căng t là không căng bằng đi dậy thôi
nhưng mà tôi vẫn ví dụ tôi luôn cầy gần
như hết tas hết t công việc này như hôm
nay hôm nay nói chung gần như là ngày
nào tôi cũng kiểu dục sếp giao thêm việc
có ông nào kiểu thế chưa ạ tôi kiểu thế
tôi dục sếp để giao thêm việc cơ Tôi
không quen kiểu đi làm để ngồi chơi đâu
thời Tôi đi học tôi đã bị quen kiểu đấy
rồi ông phải hiểu hồi đi học tôi đ như
là tôi không thể giục thầy giao thêm bài
được thế các bạn nh các bạn khác chửi
mình chết nhưng mà nhưng mà nghĩa làm
chỉ là thầy giao hết bài tập xong ấy tôi
tự nghĩ ra đề Tôi làm mà tôi xác định là
tôi đến đấy để làm cái gì ch nên đấy một
là tôi cảm thấy hôm này không muốn học
hai là bị quá quá Đau đầu quá kểu Quá
mệt hay gì gì đó tôi sẽ suy nghỉ còn một
khi mà một khi mà xác định là tôi đi học
ấy tôi chỉ học thôi tôi chỉ đúng giờ ra
đúng giờ ra chơi Tôi còn không đ nhên
giờ ra chơi thì tôi không ngồi học nhưng
mà giờ ra chơi tôi ngồi ngủ ạ tôi ngủ đ
tôi lấy sức để tí tôi ngồi học tiếp đấy
xác định quan điểm của tôi là như thế
học ra học chơ Chơi đi làm đi làm với
tôi thì mấy ông mấy ông mà là đồng
nghiệp của tôi là mấy ông xác định ngay
tôi chửi nế thì là tôi còn tôi còn gọi
nhờ nó hơi bị nó hơi bị kiểu vô lễ tí
nhưng mà nhiều lúc tôi còn kiểu V nói cả
sếp tôi rồi kìa để em kiếm việc cho anh
làm nhé thường xuyên nói thế mỗi khi mà
Sếp tôi kiểu kiểu ngồi chơi thư giãn tí
mà làm gây ảnh hưởng ấ không phải cái
ảnh hưởng gì xấu đâu nhưng nói chung là
kiểu anh trêu trêu mà đi hơi xa quá Tôi
sẽ kiểu nói thế và lúc đấy tôi sẽ rất
khó chịu ai mà kiểu đi làm mà kiểu không
ngồi tập trung làm hay là ngồi chơi các
thứ thứ điển hình nhất là một cái đứa mà
ngồi bấm giờ đợi thời gian về hay kiểu
thế Nói chung là đi làm với tôi
thì thì mấy ông sẽ thấy được sự nh nhiệt
tình kiểu có thể truyền được cảm hứng
các thứ thứ thế Kể cả không phải mỗi đi
làm nhá kể cả đi cà phê để mà để mà trao
đổi về công việc hay là để mà tôi có
khái niệm là work Dead à work
work de
đấy cả cái này thc ra khái niệm này từ
đết thì em chỉ thường hay trá gái hơn
nhưng mà ý tôi là kiểu đi cà phê để mà
ngồi làm việc cùng nhau ấy thì thì không
nói đùa đâu Tôi xác định là tôi ngồi để
tôi làm việc thật và nói chung là kiểu
đương nhiên thỉnh thoảng chúng ta sẽ
quay ngồi nói chuyện thấy gì kiểu thư
giãn hài hài chia sẻ Con không Chú yếu
mình cắm đầu pho
mà làm chơi chơi thậm chí là có quan
điểm kháca trước của thầy tôi đó là khii
chơi thì không bao giờ được nhắc chuyện
đi
làm ví dụ giờ nghỉ chưa Giờ nghỉ trưa ấy
không
không không được đề cập làm đấy Lúc đấy
Chỉ chơi thôi lúc đấy chỉ kiểu thư giã
thôi
đấy làm nhiều quá có bị mất thanh xuân
không á đừng nghĩ là tôi là một người
làm nhiều nhá tôi Tuy có thể cầy như thế
nhưng tôi không phải một người làm nhiều
ạ nếu mà ông mà gặp tôi ngoài đời điển
hình à
điển hình là như nào nhỉ ngay từ hồi
không phải đi làm đi học đi Chẳng hạn mẹ
tôi Hồi trước mẹ tôi còn nghĩ là tôi là
là đi chép bài thằng khác bởi vì điểm lú
nà cũng cao nhưng thấy về nhà chẳng h
anh gì cả không làm bài tập gần như là
rất ít khi nhìn thấy tôi ngồi ở ván học
luôn đấy Kiểu thế tôi xác định là về nhà
tôi chỉ chơi thôi còn lên lớp thì tôi
ngồi học ngồi cầy về nhà tôi chỉ chơi
thôi nên thành ra là mấy cái ông mà đi
chơi cùng tôi thì đúng là hợp lực kém
thật V cứ bị tôi dụ dỗi lôi
kéo còn đi học thì thôi đi học thì ông
phải hiểu có cái một thời cái thồi hồi
cấp hồi lớp 12 ấy hồi lớp 12 đương nhiên
là đang ôn thi để vào để vào đại học
đúng không ạ Đấy thì trường tôi kiểu
dạng là trường Tôi xa khá là xa nhà với
nhiều người nên thành ra là buổi trưa
thì ít ông kiểu về nhà nghỉ trưa rồi
quay lại trường lắm chủ yếu là
kiểu nghỉ trưa luôn ở trường mà nghỉ
trưa luôn ở trường thì thực ra có tầm
tiếng rưỡi hai tiếng thì thường là bọn
nó sẽ không ngủ trưa đâu nhiều năng
lượng vãi chưởng bọn sẽ kiểu cả lũ ra
nét ngồi nghĩa
là mua đồ ăn ở nét x ngồi chơi nét x
chiều vào ngồi học tiếp đấy Còn tôi thì
tôi đúng kiểu Hồi đấy lạc lẫm con hồi
đấy cực kỳ lạc lẫm luôn
nghĩa tôi sẽ đi ăn trưa đôi khi đi ăn
chơi một mình Sau đó thì vào vào trong
lớp kê bán ghế đi ngủ để mà có sức để mà
chiều học
đấy Nói chung là tôi xác định là kiểu
Hồi đấy Đúng kiểu dạng là ừ cắm đầu và
học các thứ và hồi đấy Đúng Hồi đấy may
mà tôi có một tí động lực đó là hồi đấy
có có bạn gái nên thành ra kiểu có gì đó
Bữa ăn tinh thần à kiểu thế kiểu nhắn
tin bạn đấy kiểu dạng để mà có có động
lực tí kểu như thế chứ không thì đúng là
cố đơn thật Ờ thế nào
nhỉ Tự nhiên nh nh nhan chuyện tình cảm
tự nhiên
lại Ok bây giờ đông hơn rồi chắc là tôi
xin phép trả lời mấy câu hỏi này giữa
winf và web thì anh nghĩ là cái nào sẽ
là xu hướng tương lai hơn ạ tôi nghe
winform vài lần rồi Như tôi không nhớ
winform là gì form winf là gì
[âm nhạc]
nhỉ À mấy kiểu app app trên desktop và
các thứ các thứ đúng không Đúng
ý xu hướng tương lai á Tôi nghĩ ở web nó
sẽ không bao giờ là ít nhất là không
biết có gì hay thế nhưng mà web tôi
nghĩa là nó là một cái gì đó Kiểu nó nó
nó sẽ không bao giờ mất đi đâu không
biết xu hướng hay không nhưng mà chắc
chắn là tôi nghĩ là rất khó để web về
sau nó sẽ mất chứ khi có gì đó kiểu một
cái phát minh ở đột phá chứ còn bây giờ
app nó còn nhúng được web nên là tôi
nghĩa là web nó sẽ mới là xu thế lu for
này đúng là tôi ít thấy hơn thật mấy ông
điển hình mấy ông thấy là mấy ông hay
truy cập trang web các th các thứ đôi
khi mấy ông có tải app gì đâu ngay ở
trên chính máy tính này này các bạn cũng
không tải hẳn một cái app là app
Facebook cho dù nó có đúng không ạ Các
bạn có tải đâu các bạn truy cập hết vằng
trình duyệt đúng không
ạ nghĩa là web nó vẫn là nó là một cái
gì đó mà chính các ông lớn đang đang
kiểu phát triển vào nó nên là chắc là
các ông lớn ấy không phát triển một cái
gì đó khác để cạnh tranh đâu trừ khi là
ví dụ ví dụ Giả sử Microsoft này không
cạnh tranh được với thằng Google về
khoản Chrome chẳng hạn làm thằng s này
nhưng mà vẫn không đủ thì lúc đấy có thể
suy nghĩ việc là là làm hẳn một cái á
riêng g gì đó nữa nhưng mà cái khó vì rõ
ràng là s này cũng đang được đầu tư khá
nhiều rồi nhưng mà đương nhiên là tôi
biết có rất nhiều đội ngũ khác nghĩa là
sao nghĩa là cái thằng s này vẫn được có
một đội ngũ phát triển hoặc là cả Cứ cho
là cả một không phải một đội ngũ mà hẳn
một cái cứ cho một công ty nhỏ để phát
triển đi vẫn sẽ có một đội ngũ để phát
triển những cái dự án mới những cái dự
án riêng nó hơi tuyệt mật một tí có thể
thế đợi khi nào mà kiểu mà đội đấy Kiểu
phát minh ra được cái xịn đấy thì mới
bắt đầu công bố Kiểu cái Thế thì chắc là
lúc đấy cái đấy mới ra đời còn không
Hiện tại thì
cái mấy cái này vẫn đang được đầu tư khá
là nhiều chắc là tôi cảm thấy không lỗi
thời được
được em muốn theo mảng làm trình Android
mà hiện nay í job nên học
iOS luôn em ngu gép ạ
vì do là cái nhu cầu tuyển dụng nhu cầu
tuyển dụng bây giờ thực ra Nói thẳng
luôn là không phải là không tuyển nhưng
mà tuyển người có Trinh độ hơn một tí
chứ em mà chạy theo xu thế là chị cứ có
cái nào thì em nhảy vào
thì nó khó chyên sâu được một cái lắm
Kiểu cái trình độ của em nó sẽ luôn chỉ
là biết nhiều chứ không biết sâu vào một
cái thì rất ít công ty tuyển đấy Cái thứ
nhất thứ hai anh không biết lý do việc
là em kém về web ở khoản nào nữa Nếu mà
em kém về web theo kiểu là
ư kiểu kém ngôn ngữ hay cái gì gì đó khó
phải ngôn ngữ nào cũng giống ngôn ngữ
nào đấy không biết trả lời cái câu này
như nào như anh nghĩ là là với anh thì
ngôn ngữ Tuy là mình thường an nói mọi
ngôn ngữ đều giống nhau nhưng mà thực tế
là tôi thấy tôi từng chia sẻ là khi bạn
codt một ngôn ngữ này nhảy sang ngôn ngữ
khác ngoài việc là mấy cố Pháp là khác
nhau nhá tư duy của các bạn sẽ khác nhau
ví dụ rõ ràng các bạn để ý rõ luôn tư
duy của một ông lập trình viên Java lâu
năm với một ông lập trình viên p lâu năm
thầy khác biệt rất rõ ít nhất là về
khoản Ừ đương nhiên là khi mà đủ lâu năm
ở đây chị cũng lên
mức 3 4 năm đi chứ còn nếu mà nếu mà
kiểu dạng còn lâu hơn ấy thì tôi nghĩ là
ông nào cũng sẽ ông nào cũng sẽ kiểu
biết nhiều ngôn ngữ thôi Nếu mà nếu mà
kiểu nên thế còn nếu mà ông nào chuyến
sâu nó nào giống như tôi chẳng hạn cũng
hơi bị bảo thù là kiểu đã làm pp được
hơn Cứ cho là hơn 7 à hơn 5 năm rồi
đấy mà vẫn chỉ biết mỗi môn ngôn ngữ pp
đấy Thì đúng là cũng có cái bảo thụ
riêng của mình và cái đấy là nó sẽ nhược
điểm của mình bởi vì mình không mạnh về
mình chỉ biết chuyên sâu mỗi pp mình
không mạnh về rất nhiều cái khác vở mỗi
ngôn ngữ khác nó sẽ có một cái thế mạnh
của nó ví dụ là Lập trình hướng những
đối tượng chuyên sâu hơn đấy các thứ các
chuyên đủ chuyên rộng một cái đã mọi thứ
tính tiếp sau
anh có dạy react không
Ừ như tôi đã nói Thực ra là tôi dạy cho
mấy ông thường là p với SQL bởi vì hai
cái đấy tôi chuyên sông cũng tương đối
và tôi đam mê Cái đấy nữa cho dù hôm
trước vừa bị bóc mẹ một cái không phải
bóc mẹ dùng từ như nào V bị góp ý một ý
là là về cái hôm trước tôi phải thử
chứng minh ấy như nhưng mà tôi về không
chứng minh được
được là cái lý thuyết về bên fq
đấy thì À đấy tôi có Đề cập về vụ này
tôi định ki này đó Hôm đấy ông ấy nói
xong thì ok mọi thứ tôi thấy lại bình
thường gì cả cũng không có vấn đề gì cả
không nhỉ Tôi có playlist dạy SQL cơ bản
đấy Ông có thể vào Xem đương nhiên là
xem xem xong Vừa xem vừa thực hành này
sau đó thì về sau ông muốn nâng trình
hơn nữa thì có hacker rank à Xong làm
thêm một vài dự án thực tế nữa thì càng
tốt chứ bài tập thì nó vẫn chỉ dừng ở
mức Ly thuyết cơ bản đấy thì hôm trước
Ông ấy góp ý xong Nói chung tôi cũng suy
nghĩ khá nhiều khi mà có người góp ý chỉ
ch mình cái Mà mình sai thì thì đương
nhiên là kiểu cũng tự ái rồi đủ kiểu có
không phải nói kiểu mình không buồn được
nhưng mà tôi l thấy khá là
hay cũng có cái hay trong đấy nhưng mà
vẫn buồn là chủ yếu thì tôi có nảy ra
suy nghĩ này không biết mấy ông nghe ổn
không Đó là kiểu tôi sẽ kểu đây reward à
nó là gọi dịch tiếng Việt nó là gì ấ nhở
tôi không biết được cái từ mỹ miều là
tiếng Việt
kiểu giải thưởng à c thứ thứ giải thưởng
ấ nó cứ kiểu bị trân trọng quái nhưng mà
ý tôi đó là kiểu ví dụ rất nhiều lúc mà
tôi đưa ra quan điểm vào đó quan điểm ở
đó không cần nhết th phải là lý thuyết
học đúng không ạ Mấy ông
à có tương tác rồi đóng góp kiểu nói
phản biện lại hay cái gì gì đó để mà chỉ
tôi cái sai cái không hợp lý các thứ các
thứ thì tôi sẽ tạo à Tôi Tôi sẽ tạo cho
gọi
là nói chung là đại khái tôi sẽ kiểu
dạng như là dùng từ như nào tôi sẽ ba
chấm đấy cho ông một cái phần thưởng
phần thưởng đây chắc là tiền mặt kiểu
thế
Ờ thế Hay mà kiểu xem có một vài kênh
youtuber hoặc là tiktoker hay đủ kiểu ấy
mấy người nổi tiếng người ta cũng thường
hay gọi là
nó không biết dùng từ Donate đúng không
thầy không bên nước ngoài dùng từ gì ý
xong đại khái là kiểu Còn trao ngẫu
nhiên cho ngẫu cho ngẫu nhiên cho một
người bất kỳ một người theo dõi bất kỳ
cơ đây là tôi không trao ngẫu nhiên tôi
chỉ trao kiểu kiểu dạng là ờ ai đóng góp
kiểu ai tương tác mình thể tôi muốn tôi
muốn là thế nghĩa là chỉ là
à không phải muốn người khác bóc mẽ m
mình mà muốn người khác kiểu đóng góc
xây dựng cùng mình bởi vì rất nhiều lúc
mình cũng sẽ sai đúng không
ạ thì khi mà khi mà người khác nhìn thấy
rồi kệ ấ người ta ngại không nói hoặc
người ta kiểu kệ mình ấy thì mình sẽ
luôn suy nghĩ quan điểm sai đấy Thì đấy
là không tốt đúng không ạ Và Và quan
trọng là như này nói chung đại khái thì
với tôi quan điểm ấy đó Kiểu mình sẽ
không biết được mặt mình đ bị có cái nhọ
ở trên mặt chẳng hạn có rất nhiều người
đi qua sẽ cười khi mà nhìn thấy cái nhọ
đấy nhưng mà người ta sẽ không nói lại
về mình nên là mình sẽ rất trân trọng
cái người nào mà chỉ ra cho mình cái
điều đấy
đấy thế tốt đúng không ạ còn hơn là mọi
mọi người sẽ kiểu tẩy chay ha chính xa
mình chỉ vì mình có vết bẩn gì đó trên
mặt nhng người ta không nói cho mình
điều đấy thì tôi không muốn mình kiểu bị
như
thế nên là khi mà mình có cái gì đó sai
mà người khác góp ý người ta kiểu giúp
đỡ mình thì mình rất là trân trọng điều
đấy chứ mình nên thế bởi vì cái người mà
kiểu thực sự kiểu để tâm để mà trân
trọng mình à để giúp đỡ mình không nhiều
đâu ạ
Ơ nãy giờ tôi à nhầm nhầm không Không
sao tôi cứ tưởng tôi bị chia màn hình bé
lại nhưng mấy ông hiểu hiểu ý tường tôi
không ạ Tôi không biết được dùng từ như
nào nữa đại khái là kiểu Ờ tôi muốn kiểu
tạo ra một cái kiểu như thế đó là ai mà
góp ý thì có tính chất xây dựng chứ
không phải vào trừ nhá thì thì tôi sẽ
tạo ra một cái
kiểu hình như th Hình như là Momo có cái
kiểu đấy thì phải cái hồi mà làm cái vụ
lý xì tôi thấy là nó sẽ có tạo ra một
cái một cái kiểu dạng như một cái tạo
cái lì xì xong rồi ai ai vào thì nó sẽ
ngẫu nhiên một cái một khoảng tiền ở đó
để mà lì xì tặng người ta
Ừ không biết còn cái cái tiện ích đấy
không
cơ
n có cái giật lì xì này Ơ nhưng mà hình
như là nó bỏ đi
tự chạy random ngẫu nhiên rồi tôi tự
thưng người ta thôi cũng được Ừ nhưng là
ý tôi V thế tôi sẽ làm thử một cái thế
hoặ ông nào biết có
cái có cái nào cũng kiểu tương tự Thế
thì bảo bà tôi thì đấy nghĩa là cứ mỗi
lần ai mà à hỗ trợ gì mình thực ra có ở
đây có cái nút để mà biến họ
thành kiểu bình thường là mấy ông sẽ có
cái nút để mà Donate cho người à người
livestream đúng không Mà có tương tác
ngược lại thì tốt nghĩa là livestream
Donate lại cho người người xem thì nó
hay đấy hiển thị lên kiểu như
thế đúng không ạ Thôi tôi ý tưởng như
thế đương nhiên là mình chắc là mình
cũng chính vì hiện tại đang cũng có
không hẳn nhiều người xem nên tôi nghĩ
là tôi làm kiểu đấy được thực ra nó cũng
chẳng có gì quá tôn
kém t vì sao mình nổi lên thực ra mình
vẫn làm cái đấy được Nếu mình chỉ cho mệ
cho cái mệnh giá kiểu tầm à Ờ từ từ 10
random từ 10 đến 100 thôi nó không phải
con số to lắm nên là tôi nghĩ hoàn toàn
được thoải
dạy c+ c em đang lấn cấn chia thời gian
học không đều
ý em cứ học song song thôi Bởi vì hồi
hồi thời gian đầu ai chẳng học một cái
ngôn ngữ cơ bản kia để hiểu V về ngôn
ngữ lập trình Không sao đâu Thời gian
đầu anh cũng anh nĩ Anh học x cộng cộng
và anh nghĩ là ai cũng học mấy cái cái
đấy chứ Anh nghĩ pp còn đáng học không ạ
Ờ thực ra mình câu
về M câu về gọi nhờ ngôn ngữ lập trình
như này chắc
là tôi nghĩ tôi nghĩ là Ừ tôi nghĩ là
kiểu hai mình sẽ bắt trước kiểu anh Tuấn
là mình làm ra con chatbot kiểu n giống
như anh ấy đang làm th anh ấy thì dùng
luôn cái thư viện có sẵn của thằng à
chpt nhưng mà ý tôi là tôi sẽ tích hợp
nó luôn ở trong livestream như thế này
và dạ như
này hình như là mình không rõ được là
hình như là có thể trên được cho nó Tôi
sẽ thử trên CH nó để trả lời Mấy cái câu
mà kiểu mà thường hay bị hỏi hỏi hỏi đi
hỏi lại nhiều như này nó trả lời hộ hộ
mình cũng khá là
Ừ để tôi thử Bảo ông em nghiên cứu vụ
nấy Xem anh em cùng làm cái
lập trình đều có cái hay của nó nên là
và mình học cái này thì nhảy sang cái
kia nên thực ra không quan trọng việc
cái nào đáng hơn cái nào cái nào hơn cái
nào mọi người cho em hỏi bị lặp trong cơ
bản với pp không thể áp
bị lý thuyết các thứ nó hơi mơ hồ một tí
thời gian đầu tôi cũng thế Tôi cũng thấy
khó mà áp dụng thực tế các thứ thứ Nói
chung phải làm một khoảng thời gian xong
rồi thấy là nó có vấn đề Nó xảy
ra lúc đấy mới biết biết được tác dụng
thực sự của oop các th thứ là như nào nó
n ná giống như là kiểu Ờ tôi tôi dạy cho
mấy ông V pp cơ bản ấy th lúc đầu là pp
thuần thôi tức là chẳng áp dụng một cái
phw chẳng áp dụng một cái mô hình nào cả
thì mấy ông thấy là code nó bị lập lại
rất là nhiều chôi về sau tôi dạy về mvc
thì mấy ông mới thấy à
Kiểu kiểu áp dụng mvc thì code nó không
bị lặp lại này nó rõ ràng nó Tưng minh
hơn này nó tiện hơn rất nhiều cái
lúc đấy mình mới kiểu nắm rõ được
JavaScript Hình như là tôi chưa làm op
JavaScript Bao giờ thì
phải với sinh viên thì nên học sâu chứ
đừng có học rộc đừng có học
rộng
Ờ anh có một cái playlist về pp à lập
trình web đấy nó bao gộ nó sẽ bao gồm cả
pp cơ bản và nâng cao đấy em thể xem
tham khảo nhá
vân không biết đi theo full stack hay
Android các bạn vẫn thường hay hỏi chung
về một cái vụ kiểu ngôn ngữ
bỏ qua nó cứ bị lập lại nhiều ấy Chào
anh em là À Chào anh em là sinh viên
năm2 ngày hô n thì đang học trường này
học làm thêm cả tiện lợi Do kinh tế khó
khăn nên phải đi làm
à thầ Nó chiếm thời gian khá nhiều thời
gian học ngành này Đúng rất nhiều bạn cả
sinh viên tôi hiện tại cũng thấy nó là
chi kiểu các bạn đấy học cả ngày rồi số
tối còn đi làm thêm Nói chung
là nếu các bạn hoàn cảnh khó khăn quá
thì đúng là nó một cái trường ngại khá
là lớn
à nó làm ảnh hưởng việc học các thứ các
bạn phải sắp xếp lại mà sắp xếp thực ra
là tôi cũng thấy nói bài toán hơi năn
giải một tí vì rõ ràng vì rõ ràng nhá
Ờ các bạn đi học à các bạn à Gì à
Ờ các bạn đi
[âm nhạc]
trại tương đối cuộc sống hiện tại chú đ
đi học ngành công nghệ tin này nó nó vẫn
tính là nó vẫn hơi mô hồ Nếu mà giả sử
các bạn không chịu khó mà có thể có thể
không biết được có tỉ lệ các bạn không
phù hợp với ngành này thành ra là kiểu
nó sẽ bị áp lực gánh nặng thêm rất nhiều
nhưng mà thường là tôi thấy là thường
những bạn
mà đã kiểu đi làm như này rồi ý mà vẫn
theo ngành ấy thì bạn đấy có độ Quyên
tâm cao phết nên là nên là tôi tư vấn
thì thật ra hơi khó tư vấn
nhỉ tôi biết có nhiều bạn
có rất nhiều hoàn cảnh mà nên khó mà trả
lời
ờ ừ đúng rồi Tôi có biết một bạn
này bạn đấy Khi mà lên khi lên đã học là
gia đình gần như là sẽ không hề trang
trải bất kỳ cái khoản
nào cho việc học bạn đấy Bạn hình như là
bạn ấy tự đi vay ngân hàng để bạn ấy có
tiền trả tiền học à và trong thời gian
đấy thì bạn đấy Cố học nhanh nhất có thể
để bạn ấy có thể đi làm đấy
được cho các bạn về mấy cái khoản này
không các bạn thể cân nhắc
Xem xem Đấy là một đấy là một cách đúng
không ạ Không biết Không biết về mấy vụ
này nhưng mà bạn tôi bạn ấy từng chia sẻ
tôi như thế đấy một cách để mà kiểu mình
xác định là mình mình theo ngành này và
xác định phải học để mà ra ngoài làm Nếu
mà thực sự muốn muốn học chứ nếu mà vừa
học vừa làm thì đúng là khó để mà học
được
đấy được không
ạ và ngân hàng thì Nếu có thể thì vay
nhá Đừng có vay tín dụng tín dụng đen
hay là vay sã hội đen C thử thử nhá nhá
Không nên nhá
các bạn có thể chia sẻ nhá Tôi tôi mới
nghĩ là được mỗi cái kiểu như
thế em muốn học cấu trúc dữ liệu và giải
thuật nhưng thnh phải thành thạo Một
ngôn ngữ thì thế nào là để là thành thạo
để học
mà để thành thạo được một cái gì đó
theo tôi là ít nhất là các bạn cũng sẽ
phải mất tầm 1000 cho đến 1000 giờ là để
mà các bạn kiểu quen và hiểu rõ bản chất
cũng tương đối về nó đấy
à Còn 10.000 giờ là các bạn đ thành kiểu
cũng tương đối là gê gớm trong cái đấy
rồi thì theo tôi là để học cái gì đó các
bạn 1000 giờ và hoặc là cứ Choo tầm 3
tháng Để mà nghiên cứu một cái g đó đi
để mà các bạn biết qua rõ B cũng biết
qua bản chất mọi thứ thứ sau đó là các
bạn sẽ quyết định tiếp xem là là kiểu
mình có phù hợp với nó hay
không thử nha
Ok các bạn đôi khi đừng có nghĩ gì cả
các bạn cứ nghĩ đôi khi là nó cũng vẫn
chưa trong lúc các bạn đang ngồi nghĩ
đang măn khoăn là kiểu có nên đi con
đường này hay không người ta đã cắm đầu
vào đi rồi đấy nên người ta kiểu gì đang
đi trước trước bạn nếu mà người ta mà có
thất bại người ta thấy nó là ngõ cụt đối
với người ta thì họ quay lại họ rẽ rồi
trong lúc đấy mình vẫn đang dậm chân tại
chỗ ở giữa ngã tư mình vẫn đang băn
khoăn r không biết nên đi hay không
Các bạn cứ hỏi để lặp đi lập lại thì nó
đúng là kiểu vài cái lạp lại thật thế n
Tôi bảo là kiểu đôi khi một buổi
livestream chỉ ngồi trả lời câu hỏi các
bạn bạn hết sử thời
muỗi đợi tỷ đợi tôi một tỷ tôi phải lắp
cái đèn hút muội
hàng làm việc thế nào Nhưng mà tôi thấy
tôi tôi có biết ngân hàng và một vài
trường là có hỗ trợ đóng học phí rồi các
thứ các thứ để cho để cho mình xác định
là kiểu học ấy nói chung là hãy tìm cách
để mà sao cho mình tập trung học sau đó
thì đương nhiên là các bạn Tôi cũng có
khuyên sinh viên Tôi đi làm p ham không
phải full time Nếu mà có thể ví dụ là
cái thời gian mà không học mấy môn Đại
không học mấy hôn môn trên ngành ấy mà
bị rảnh rội quá ấy rảnh rỗi thường hay
sinh nông nổ lắm rảnh rảnh rỗi thường
hay kiểu suy nghĩ linh tinh đôi khi lại
cắm đầu
vào cái chuyện không hay nhiều đấy
thì mình vẫn có thể nên đi làm part time
để mà trải nghiệm môi trường tăng thêm
kỹ năng mềm có một tí thu nhập gì gì đó
và cái quan trọng đó là Trân trọng Trân
trọng đồng tiền này trân trọng thời gian
kiểu mình cảm thấy là ví dụ như tôi từng
bảo là năm nhất Tôi làm đủ mọi nghề ấ
thì tôi chuẩn nhận ra tôi không hề phù
hợp bất kỳ cái nghề nào trong nôm đấy cả
thấy là tôi ngồi làm máy tính Tôi thích
kiểu kiếm được nhiều Nói thẳng luôn là
kiếm được nhiều tiền một cách dễ dàng
hơn đối với tôi thì tôi cảm thấy là làm
kiểu kia nó kiếm nó khó khăn hơn chẳng
hạn Vân Vân đấy thì lúc mà đi học thì
mình sẽ cắm đầu vào học hơn thôi lúc đấy
mình sẽ không hề băn khoăn suy nghĩ
không hề suy nghĩ giống như mấy ông hiện
tại luôn rất nhiều mấy ông hiện tại tôi
không Tôi không nói về mấy ông hoàn cảnh
thế nào vì tôi không làm rõ được nhưng
mà có thể là mấy ông hoàn cảnh có khi
còn có có điều kiện hơn tôi một tí về
khoản là mấy ông còn b đang băn khoăn
tôi hồi đấy là tôi không thể băn khoăn
được luôn lúc đấy Tôi không có đường lui
không Có đường không có đường lùi không
có thể quay đầu lại không thể làm lại gì
đó mình đã chọn Cái này mình chỉ cắm đầu
mà đi thôi Bởi vì không đi không đi có
làm được cái gì khác đâu Chỉ cắm đâu và
đi thôi đi đến cuối cuối con đường mà ra
ra Kiểu kiểu gọn nh đi Đế Cuối con đường
mà nó ra được cái gì thì ra đấy Kiểu thế
phải chấp nhận ri ro là như thế May mà
nó cũng nên cơm cháo gì đó chứ chứ kiểu
các bạn cứ kiểu cứ nghĩ kiểu mình có nên
cái này không mình nên kia không trong
khi mà mọi người đang cắm đầu đi rồi thì
mình cũng bị run đấy nhưng mà vẫn còn
đứng đấy vẫn còn đang măn khoăn lên hay
không thì nó bị lãng phí thời gian thật
cắm đầu và đi Thấy không phù hợp thì
quay đầu không sao tuổi trẻ mình có điều
đấy mà mình có dư giả nhất là thời gian
ấy
đấy mà không phải xác định mấy cái quan
điểm các thứ thứ Thế thì mình gọi là
cuộc sống nó sẽ dễ dễ thở hơn cái gì mà
mình nghĩ được thì mình nghĩ còn cái gì
mà mình không không nghĩ được ví dụ ở
đấy các bạn hỏi một người lạm mặt ở trên
mạng hoặc là gì gì đó hoặc bất kỳ ai
chẳng ai có thể hiểu rõ được các bạn cả
và chẳng ai biết được các bạn hợp hay
thực sự muốn cái gì Cái gì tốt nhất cho
bạn và gọi
nh chung rất nhiều tôi thực ra từng
khuyên cái này khá nhiều
một như nét
mau không hề biết cái nét ma kia là cái
gì luôn
cho
à multiple app à Nghe cũng hợp lý nhỉ
chưa biết cái này nhưng nghe tiềm năng
ấy chứ thử
mạng máy tính có quan trọng khi phỏng
vấn interm không
ạ
h Em làm về hệ thống à mà phải phải biết
về hai cái đấy nhỉ Nếu mà em Làm lập
trình viên thì ra cái đấy không bao giờ
được hỏi
luôn Ông có thể chia sẻ về quán quá
trình interm của ông được không Tôi Tôi
làm à Hồi mà tôi đi thực tập thì tôi hồi
đấy Cái thời gian
đầu cái thời gian đầu là gì nh Ờ tôi
chẳng biết làm cái gì cả hai tuần đầu
tôi xác định chẳng biết làm gì cả Bởi vì
toàn bộ toàn bộ kiến thức rất là mới
người ta vứt cho mấy cái link trang chủ
của mấy cái kiểu mấy cái công nghệ ví dụ
Hồi đấy tôi làm Mội Hồi đấy hồi đi lại
học thì chỉ biết mỗi p
thuần mvc op xong rồi HTML CS ra scrip
cơ bản xong rồi đi làm thì người ta vứt
cho cái fw l xong rồi thư viện jquery
xong rồi fw boot chat hồi đấy Kiểu đọc
hai tuần liền Ừ thì mình biết tiếng Anh
cơ bản đấy nhá mà kiểu nó toàn bộ mơ hồ
lắm Bởi vì chưa bao giờ động đến mấy cái
đấy đúng không ạ Đấy xong rồi người ta c
xong rồi anh ấy cứ bảo là em cứ làm
những tính năng cơ cơ bản bằng những cái
đấy đi rồi dần dần em sẽ hiểu đấy thì
làm thôi bắt tay vào làm
rồi dần dần kiểu mình hiểu hiểu dần hơn
vì còn tham khảo được code của mấy anh n
trước thì mình cũng kiểu bắt trước mình
sửa lại có thử thứ xong rồi Đương nhiên
là mình gọi là học lỏm là nhiều chứ
không thể tự tự phát triển lên được một
cái gì đó Xong rồi mãi về sau thì mới
khi phải đến n đến 6 tháng lúc mà Nói
chung là tôi thực tập hồi đây lâu thật
phải nm phải đến sáu tháng thì tôi mới
cảm thấy là Ừ bây giờ mình có vẻ ngon
lành rồi mình phải làm chủ được công
nghệ cái thử thử lúc rồi em mới để xuất
đ sếp là kiểu
Ờ Bây giờ em muốn làm nhân viên chính
thước vì em cảm thấy em tự tin em làm
được việc rồi
đấy trước đấy Thực ra tôi vẫn code được
vẫn có thể làm mấy cái tool Facebook Hồi
đấy tôi cũng có chia sẻ m cái tool
Facebook nhỏ nhỏ nhưng nói chung là chỉ
Đán giả là mới dừng ở việc code được Chứ
thực ra để làm chủ công nghệ thì nó cũng
phải tốn một khoảng thời gian khi mà nó
quá tải cái thứ mới và tôi không tự tin
Tôi là một người học nhanh thôi không
Tôi không cảm thấy tự tin mình người học
nhanh Nói thẳng luôn là mình là một
người kiểu cũng nghĩ nhiều hiểu hơi hơi
chậm một tí đặ biệt bây giờ trẻ B giờ
hiểu còn nhanh nữa tôi cảm thấy cả ngày
mình cũng bắt đầu lỗi thời rồi đấy nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ là tôi vẫn chỉ hơn người
được cái là
tôi cái tinh thần của tôi Ấy và cái nói
chung là cái lý trí cái ý chí tinh thần
mọi thứ ấy tôi khá là cao thậm chí là
kiểu có người tiến bối những người mà có
nhiều năm kinh nghiệm hơn nói mình mình
mình cũng hơi bảo thủ mình hơi có cái
tôi mình cũng kiểu có trính kiến rê của
mình người ta nói mình chắc gì mình C
nghe mình cứ nghe xong rồi mình mình
cũng không Không luôn cho là người ta
đúng mình vẫn có kiểu vẫn đương nhiên
vẫn phải mở mang học hỏi nhá
không phải là là kiểu dạng x ngồi đây
rng coi trời bằng vung đâu Mình vẫn
Nhưng mà quan trọng là mình à phải học
hỏi có chọn lọc cũng như là
ừ dạng nhà nhỉ Không phải ai không phải
ai nói gì cũng là mọi thứ tốt cho mình
mọi thứ phù hợp với mình mình cũng phải
điều chỉnh lại sao cho nó phù hợp với
mình đúng không ạ chung là rất nhiều
không ạ
Ờ đến bây giờ tôi cũng không làm chủ nó
n Tôi không biết khuyên mấy ông cái gì
đứ nhờ ở công ty tôi cài bây giờ tôi
càng tôi càng phải code hướng đối tượng
hơn và kiểu biết design nó clean hơn vân
vân Nhưng
mà có những cái tôi từng chia sẻ mấy ông
ấy Nghĩa là khi mà khi mà
đừng đã từng tôi đã từng thấy có vài anh
Master Nói thẳng luôn đó
là đừng dùng dao mổ trâu để đi mổ gà Tức
là sao Đừng đôi khi là đừng nghĩ làm một
cái gì đó phức tạp quá khi mà V ví dụ
hồi trước điển hình cái code làm cái dự
án pancham kia kìa tôi có chia sẻ mấy
ông r Thực ra tôi không kiểu design gì
đó quá phức tạp Tôi code Mọi thứ vẫn xử
lý miễn là xử lý bài toán nghiệp vụ cứ
không nghĩ việc là mình phải thiết kế gì
đó quá phức tạp vì tính năng thực ra nó
cũng không có quá gì
đó kiểu dạng là ghê gớm để mà mình phải
làm kiểu lập trình kiểu sâu hơn các thứ
thứ tự nhiên là mình lại phải tốn thời
gian ngồi nghĩ và tốn thời gian tự Build
một cái gì đó rất là xịn trong khi đó
thứ nhất là chỉ có một hai người làm cái
đấy thôi chẳng hạn và tính năng mọi thứ
đều cơ bản thì có khi là chỉ cần đúng
kiểu m vc nghĩa là chỉ mình chỉ cần
à xử lý ở trong mua đồ hoặc là
controller là đủ rồi
đấy Đừng làm mọi thứ phức tạp vấn đề lên
khi mà có một cái bài toán phức tạp gì
đó xảy ra thôi lúc đấy mình mới cân nhắc
việc là mình áp dụng cái nào đó sau
không sao
nhiều không anh
ờ không biết thị trường ngoài kia nào
lâu lắm tôi không cập nhật luôn ấy Tôi
nhớ lần cuối Tôi đăng xin hộ mấy ông về
mấy cái công việc về pp ở trên len tôi
treo một đống tin nhận đang trời ông đấy
thì hồi đấy t tường tác rất là cao nhưng
không biết bây giờ thế
à
inter thì kiến thức bao nhiêu là đủ vậy
anh không biết trả lời câu l nốt vì à
Ừ theo theo tôi thì bản chất là inter
fer thì nó vẫn là dừng mức
là hiểu được là người ta giao cho mình
công việc gì nhưng mà mình chưa đủ
à chưa đủ tầm để mà kiểu đưa quyết định
là mình
à mình mình vẫn phải cần người chỉ lối
để mình làm cái gì đó chứ không phải là
tự mình quyết định được đấy Còn nếu tự
mình quyết định được thì tôi nghĩ là lên
là mức Junior
học fanel có cần học re không anh re Anh
nghĩ học cho vui thôi về sau em toàn
copy re ở trên mạng chứ không cần phải
chên ser re
đâu học qua cho biết thì cũng khá là hay
nói chung là cái gì cũng nên gọi nh
không hn cái gì gì nên biết một tí nhưng
mà cái đấy tô nhớ có nằm trong cái một
cái gì đó Mình cũng cần biết đối với lập
trình
viên cần biết một tí biết qua cuộc pháp
để hiểu thôi Xong về sau vẫn là cóp trên
mạng luôn mà nhưng mà Ít ra mình có hiểu
tác dụng của nó để V sau mình ứng dụng
vào để mình tra trên mạng mình còn hiểu
mình cái có cái đoạn gì về đúng không
cóp về mình không hiểu thì hơi buồn cười
anh nghĩ sau về phỏng vấn inter 1 giờ
hỏi về chuyến môn mà vẫn
Nhưng mà phòng vấn 1 giờ một tiếng đồng
hồ thì công nhận là cũng lâu phết đấy
Ờ thế là có thể kiến thức chuyên môn này
Ờ chưa đủ nên người ta hỏi thêm mấy câu
nữa để nắm rõ nhưng mà cái thái độ của
em thì đủ để người ta cân nhắc Nói chung
không biết được được hoặc Đôi khi chỉ
đơn giản là à họ họ cũng tương đối gọi
là chấm Mình 78 rồi nhưng mà tại K tự
nhiên lại có ông phỏng vấn sau ông ấy
được 9 10 nên thôi bỏ ông đi Cái này
nhiều
lắm
thấy đúng rồi Phỏng vấn inter mà tận một
tiếng công nhận gắt đúng
không em học fan en thì có cần học cái
cá à qua quan trọng là nên tập mấy cái
tận dụng tập áp dụng mấy cái kiểu tdd á
Ý ông ở kiểu vừa nãy Đề cập về uop đúng
không Ừ nếu mà áp dụng mọi thứ tập Dần
làm mấy cái dự án dần kiểu áp dụng dần
thì được thì tốt không sao cả nhưng mà ý
tôi là đừng có đặt nặng nó quá Vì chính
tôi chính tôi làm thì thì Ok có thể là
tôi non ở xanh không biết được nhưng mà
tôi cũng từng thấy rất nhiều dự án nó
không áp dụng gì đó quá ghê gớm về mấy
cái kiểu design các thứ các thứ đươ
nhiên là mấy dự án đấy có thể thiếu
chuyên nghiệp hay gì gì đó nhưng mà gọi
nh Sếp tôi thường ha nói câu đó là đôi
khi là phải cái đừng đừng đánh giá nó
qua kiểu qua về ngoài nó vẫn làm ba tiền
là được đấy Kiểu
thế nó có thể code nó hơi bị Thố Thiện
ha các thứ code gọi là cứ cho là nói
thẳng luôn COD rác đi nó vẫn làm ba tiền
mà vẫn ứng dụng được thì nó vẫn là một
cái phần mềm chạy được còn nói thẳng
luôn không một cái phần mềm nà hoàn hảo
cả kể cả cho tủ code của cả bên Google
hay bất cứ cái công ty lớn nào Kiểu gì
nó trong đấy cũng có một cái đống giác
nà Đó cái đống giác mà không ai muốn
động vào có không kể cả cho dù bất kỳ
công ty chuyên nghiệp nào cũng thế thôi
nó luôn có một cái mớ gì đó không ai
muốn động vào ờ Tại sao lại có mấy cái
mớ kiểu thế rõ ràng bên họ chuyên nghiệp
bên họ có thể áp dụng mấy cái đ design
các thứ thứ có nhưng mà thời gian đầu họ
kiểu gì họ cũng tự tạo ra một cái mơ
giác nào đó và do nó chạy được rồi nên
không ai động vào nghĩa là về sau khi mà
Mấy ông cần áp dụng về sau không thể des
sau và sẽ có một cái mớ giác nào đó mà
vốn nó chạy được rồi nên là ông sẽ để
nguyên đấy Không sao cả Nói chung khi
cần thì mới áp dụng lại bài toán Hồi
trước Sếp tôi từng dạy đó là just in
Just Just In Time tức là kiểu khi đúng
lúc thì mình mới áp dụng đừng có
cứ chưa làm gì mình đã ngồi nghĩ quá xa
như thế thì mình sẽ kiểu tốn khá nhiều
thời gian cho mấy cái mà gọi như nà Sếp
tôi hôm trước tôi bảo sếp tôi là ứng
dụng cái này ứng dụng cái kia S rồi xếp
toàn bà bây giờ ứng dụng vào thì em thấy
là nó tăng năng suất lên bao nhiêu hiệu
quả mọi thứ lên bao nhiêu nó có đáng để
mà mình bỏ ra ngần đấy TH thời gian chỉ
chỉ mà kiểu Em phải xác định vì ví dụ
phải có con số thực tế đôi khi nói
chuyện với các sếp là phải số thực tế ví
dụ Giả sử nhá tôi bảo tôi làm tối ưu cái
phần thanh toán chẳng hạn thô sế bảo là
hiện tại đang mất bao lâu ví dụ thì hiện
tại Thanh Toàn đang mất mù 1,5 giây đi
cể thế x tôi bảo tối ưu lên thành tôi
bảo tôi sẽ tối ưu x bảo em tố ưu lên lên
được thành con số bao nhiêu Nếu mà em
tốn tận mất Tận hai tuần ên mà tối ưu mà
chỉ lên được
1,4 thì nó kiểu em thà làm cái công việc
khác Thời gian đấy em làm ưu tiên làm
những cái việc khác nó còn hơn đấy hoặc
là chắc gì em làm đã tối ưu lên được
nhất đâu nó nó vẫn là 1,5 giây thì sao
em cứ nghĩ nó tối yêu nhưng thực ra
không phải sao đấy đúng không đấy em
phải chắc chắn việc là nó lên và nó lên
một cái cái xứng đáng ấy nó lại là bài
toán hồi trước trước tôi không biết từng
chia sẻ mới ông chưa Nó 20
80 Đôi khi mình chỉ cần tốn 20 ph thời
gian để ngồi làm 80 ph khối lượng công
việc nhưng nhưng mà các bạn để mà hoàn
thiện nó để mà làm mọi thứ nó hoàn hảo
ấy cái thứ nó bé bé các bạn tốn gấp bốn
lần thời gian để làm 20
ph còn lại đấy nghĩa là mất 80 PH
thời gian để làm 20 ph cái bé bé còn lại
đấy đó bài toán 2080 các bạn đôi khi các
bạn h rất nhiều lúc Sếp muốn mình làm
cái phần 80 ph công việc kia thôi không
cần nhất thiết hoàn hảo ví dụ Giả sử
Điền hình nhất nhá Tôi thường hay viết
mấy cái test cây để
mà test auto test ấy để cho nó bắt lỗi
rất nhiều các trường hợp thì đương nhiên
là tôi ngồi nghĩ kiểu hơi cao siêu hơi
ca cao xa tí nh đâu về sau nó vẫn phát
sinh ra trường hợp dị dị thì sao nó gây
vấn đề gì đó sao nên tôi cứ ngồi nghĩ
thêm mà viết test rồi xếp bảo thực ra em
chỉ cần viết test mức tương đối kiểu thứ
nhất là phải à Có những cái Happy K và
những cái trường hợp mà khả thi Nó chạy
được tốt đã số những trường hợp khả thi
Nó chạy thất bại tương đối thôi làm sao
mình có thể viết hết test toàn bộ tất cả
Test C tất cả hả trường hợp được đấy
Mình không cần quá suy nghĩ quá nhiều
vào nó khi mà có vấn đề nào đó xảy ra
thì mình viết sau mình làm mình mình
viết thêm để sửa nó sau còn bây giờ thời
gian bây giờ mình vẫn ưu tiên làm việc
khác
đó Nói chung là mình phải sắp xếp được
quỹ thời gian của mình mình ưu tiên làm
cái gì trước lúc này mình nên làm gì
trước đúng không ạ Chúng ta chúng ta
chính xác là chúng ta không phải chạy
đua với nhau đâu Chúng ta đang chạy đua
với thời gian kiểu gì Các bạn vẫn sẽ làm
được việc kiểu gì Các Bạn sẽ có việc vân
vân Nhưng
mà nó là khoảng thời gian nào thôi Kiểu
gì Các bạn sẽ có ng yêu kiểu gì Các bạn
sẽ có vợ con hoặc là trừ khi các bạn
à Chừ khi các bạn chọn độc thân thì
không biết nhá Nhưng mà nếu các bạn
hướng đến điều đấy Kiểu gì Các bạn sẽ có
quan trọng lúc nào thời gian nào đúng
không ạ Nếu các bạn mà sắp xếp mọi thứ
thời gian hợp lý nĩ lúc này cắm đầu vào
làm này lúc này cắm đầu và kiếm ng yêu
này hay các D thứ phân bổ thời gian rõ
thì cái đấy nó sẽ đến nhanh còn nếu mà
các bạn
kiểu bị nó cuốn ấy bị cuộc sống nó cuốn
đi ấ đấy x bị rất nhiều thứ nó cm dỗ hay
Vân Vân bị rất nhiều lời tác động của
tất cả mọi người để mình không hiểu rõ
bản thân mình cần gì và làm được tốt
công việc gì lúc này
ấ thì nó sẽ đến rất lâu
và khi cơ hội đến ví dụ khi người đấy
đến bạn lại chưa Sẵn sàng cho điều
đấy thì bạn lại tuột mất đúng không ạ
Vân Vân đấy Ôi tự nhiên đang từ Podcast
à Đang từ trả lời câu hội chuyển qua
Podcast chữ chữ lành hay chữa rách thì
không
mà nhiều người Nhanh nhỉ lập trình
có tôi ở công ty tôi bây giờ thực ra
công ty tôi bây giờ tôi bọ tôi đường An
kiểu viết viết code rồi mới viết test cơ
nhưng mà viết theo kiểu viết test xong
rồi viết code n cũng khá là
là tốt các thứ được đúng không ạ
interm Có cần luyện l
code các bạn đôi khi dùng cái từ kiểu
tôi
không không dùng mấy cơ à Một bên nào đó
để mà
kiểu chuẩn bị cho
ừ thực R là không cần th đượ gắt ga này
Đâu nhưng mà ông tôi nghĩ là ông thử
cũng không thừa đâu và bây giờ cạnh
tranh cạnh tranh lớn
kết nói chung các kiến thức nâng cao SQL
chă kết thì thì nó chă kết thôi mà còn
nếu Nếu mà để mà thành thạo cái gì đó
thì thôi Thứ nhất là làm nhiều thứ hai
là với SQL thì
phải phải làm phải kiểu va chạm vào vài
cái database thực tế để mà biết thêm
nhiều góp nhìn chơ lý thuyết thôi tôi
thấy nó bị suông ấy tôi từng thấy rất
nhiều người biết rõ lý thuyết nhưng
mà ra ngoài kiểu bị cứng nhắc rồi Vân
Vân ấy nói chung là nó một cái hồi trước
tôi ấy từng kiểu cũng bị cứng nhắc như
thế về thiết kế database về cái chuẩn
hóa thử thử X về sau thì mới nhận ra
thì nó là
cái thực ra nó chỉ lý thuyết Nếu mà nói
ngắn gọn theo kiểu là đơn giản ấy suy
nghĩ đơn giản ấy nó chỉ đơn giản là cái
cái database lý tưởng ổn ấy thứ nhất là
chẳng có cái nào cả cái gì cũng có cái
ưu và nhược nó thôi Cái datab lý tưởng
chỉ đơn giản là nó ứng dụng được vào
trong công việc ứng dụng được vào trong
cái giải pháp à Nó là một cái giải pháp
ứng dụng được cho cái phần mềm
đấy nó vẫn đang chạy được vẫn đang chạy
tốt và khiến cho anh em tiện trong cái
việc code lập trình gọi là tiện ở đây là
tiện
nhá vân vân vừa tiện này và vừa tối ưu
một phần nào đó về cái tốc độ các thứ
thử chứ thực ra không có một cái
database nào được thiết kế hoàn hảo cả
đấy thế nên là khi mà không thiết kế
hoàn hảo thì đồng nghĩa việc là cái truy
vấn hay là mọi thứ SQL của mình nó cũng
sẽ phải linh hoạt linh động nên là lý
thuyết nó vẫn chỉ dừng ở lý thuyết thôi
phải áp dụng thực tế rất
nhiều được không ạ chứ Rõ ràng là lý
thuyết là phải thiết kế bên như này xu
từ đó thì mình sẽ có những cái câu truy
vấn như này nhưng mà không thực tế nó
khác rất nhiều nên là thành ra tôi thấy
khó để mà làm chủ được một cái gì đó
mình chỉ đơn giản Mình thực hành nhiều
thôi ba chạm nhiều thế nên là đấy do mà
là mấy cái kiểu da hoặc da kiểu database
architect ấ databas analyst à hay là
data analyst vân vân người ta vẫn đò hỏi
người có kinh nghiệm thì tốt người đấy
từng va chạm các thứ chứ không phải là
một người mà học rất kỹ về database có
chứng chỉ về SQL chưa đủ đâu
nhá mình phòng vấn với pm và lad xong
tex thì họ bảo H sẽ tro đổi sa thương
kết quả sao thường thì bao nhiêu ngày sẽ
có kết quả nhỉ thường là chậm nhất là
chắc một tuần
mình học cơ sợ liệu không anh có dạy có
cái playlist fq cơ bản đấy Còn em muốn
tra thêm một vài cái nguồn nữa thì th
cũng có giống như tôi bảo có hacker rank
để mà kiểu nâng cao này hoặc là gọi nhở
hồi trước là tôi cũng cũng đập qua bên w
w3 school à để mà tra Mấy cái câu lệnh
này hồi đấy còn học thêm ở trên trang
nào
nha code academy Vy nhưng mà tôi không
rõ là bây giờ nó có tính phí hay không
thôi Nói chung là tôi cũng học qua một
vài Online kiểu đọc thực hành qua một
vài trang online miễn phí nhưng mà cũng
chỉ một thời gian đầu thôi Chú yếu là
học trên trường thôi áp dụng các thứ thứ
dần dần ấy nó thêm kinh nghiệm thôi từ
lúc ra trưởng Anh làm mấy công ty
rồi Nếu mà chính xác D từ lớp ra trường
đến giờ tôi mới làm ở một công ty gần
đây là mới đi dạy Ờ cái trường mới này ơ
Chắc hai công ty tại sao thế bởi vì hồi
trước là đi thực tập thì đi thực tập vng
một công ty xong
rồi Được được mở lại dạy nên thành ra
lại qua Đại Trường Thành nà tính nào
chưa ra trường đấy sau lúc mà vừa ra
trường xong thì về công ty này và làm
đến bây giờ tính ra tôi chỉ mới làm ở
một công ty
Mobile nhiều nhiều mạng khác hay là học
thêm back end back end để có thể đa di
năng vậy ạ
Ừ em cứ học thêm thôi không sao em cứ
học thêm xong rồi Em cảm thấy phù hợp
kểu có thời gian để học thì thì tốt biết
đâu Em cảm thấy là mình phù hợp sang
mảng khác nữa em phải nhưng mà em phải
xác định rõ giống như hôm trước anh cũng
phải cố trả lời câu hỏi là mình muốn
hiểu sâu Hay là mình muốn hiểu rộng ấy
anh Bởi vì anh đặc biệt là bởi vì mình
qu tâm việc là mình Thứ nhất là mình
cũng sợ việc là mình sẽ bị thay thế thứ
hai là mình sẽ bị lỗi thời vân vân nên
là mình à Nên mình cảm thấy là mình có
thể học sâu hay học rộn đấy các bạn phải
tự quyết định được Rất là càng sớm càng
tốt Bởi vì tôi thì tôi xác định rõ là
tôi có thể thể không học sâu được này vì
tôi khó mà ngồi đọc tài liệu có th thứ
thì đương nhiên là về pp hay làq thì tôi
đang học tương đối sâu tôi gọi là cũng
tương đối tương đối thôi Cho dù Nếu mà
bây giờ hỏi
thêm áp dụng thêm rất nhiều cái sâu hơn
cái xịn hơn của thằng pp Có khi mình vẫn
chưa biết Nhưng mà đại khá là mình cũng
hiểu rõ khá nhiều rồi tương đối rồi
nhưng mà tính là tôi tôi Tôi cảm thấy
khó mà sâu hơn được nữa nên là tôi sẽ
đang chuyển qua dần thành học rộng kiểu
biết rộng biết các
thứ bạn đá sang thêm nhiều mảng
nữa Nói chung là các bạn phải nắm rõ
được việc mình có thể học thế nào có thể
nghiền ngẫm được sách các thứ thứ sách
chuyên sâu hơn được nữa không có nên ghi
thêm Số năm kinh nghiệm nếu có đủ khả
năng không không không nên ghi phóng đại
gì ch đó quá em ạ tức cả ghi vẫn chỉ ở
mức gọi tương đối xong rồi khi phỏng vấn
thì thì mình trả lời được là được chứ
còn mình phóng đại lên thì nói chung là
không bao giờ nên chém gió ở trong civ
theo tôi thì như thế Hồi trước là có
người bảo nên chém gió nhưng mà chỉ là
mức tương đối không biết thế nào tương
đối nữa Bởi vì nếu mà ghi vào kỳ vọng
người ta lại kỳ vọng mình cao quá người
ta hỏi những câu khó quá mình đều không
trải được tự nhiên mình bị mất điểm hơi
nhiều đúng không ạ nên theo tôi ở mức
tương đối thôi Ờ à mức kiểu Nếu hạn chế
được Hạn chế Bởi vì đươ nhiên có sẽ có
nhược điểm Nếu giả sử ông Viết Tv mà
không đủ gây ấ tượng mà những cái ông
khác nổ hơn ông chẳng hạn thì ông sẽ bị
loại từ lúc mà trước khi phỏng vấn nên
là nói chung là phải tự Ông cảm thấy cái
CV của ông đang như thế nào đã Nó trầm
nó chấm tầm mấy điểm ví dụ Ông thấy là
78 thì ổn rồi còn nếu mà dừng mức 56 đ
như phải nổ lên hoặc là hoặc là ông phải
phấn đấu lên 78 thật thì lúc ấy ông
không phải nổ nữa đấy nếu mà được như
thế
tốt cò Nếu 9 10 thì thôi Quan tâm gì về
CV nữa đúng không
Project để ghi vào đi làm các thứ đang
học nét học
sava à Em thầ học làm ch sâ ngôn ngữ nào
đó em chưa xác định
được Thế học cả hai cái đấy vẫn tôi thấy
là nó vẫn bổ trợ nhau chứ tôi biết có
anh biết cả hai cái
đấy làm Project K th ra thì các bạn cứ
làm mấy cái giống như là tôi chia sẻ ở
trên kênh làm mấy cái đồ án chyên sâu và
nên làm quản lý một cái gì
đó để làm rõ bài toán nghiệp vụ một cái
gì đó Có thể bắt trước một cái trang web
hay một cái phần mềm nào đó đã từng có
rồi Mình làm lại kiểu các tính năng như
thế xem mình hiểu rõ được cơ chế hoạt
động nó hay không vân vân cũng
được Nó nói chung là làm sao mà có thể
áp dụng có thể dùng nó để áp dụng được
trong bài toán thực tế được dùng được ý
chứ không phải làm trong một cái thứ mà
không dùng được thì như là không được
đánh giá
cao học COD trường nào thì thích hợp để
đi thực tập vậy ạ đấy Làm được cái đồ án
chuyên sâu như trên kia thì hoàn toàn hể
À xin đi thực tập được rồi lúc đấy m
cũng gọi là hiểu để làm từ đầu đến cuối
một cái sản phẩm nào đó rồi đấy Ok ạ Anh
học ngôn ngữ nào thì
à Thì tôi học
và đầu tiên là hình như là chính tôi ghi
câu này vậy ngoài mấy ngôn ngữa lớp
trình thì thực ra là
tôi định học thêm cả
à biết tiếng anh một tí này và tôi đang
định học là tiếng Trung nữa cải thiện
thêm vì tôi định sang bên chung để mà
kiểu kiểu đi khám phá xong rồi đi du
lịch các thứ học hỏi các thứ được g tốt
thì chắc chắn là học thêm ngôn ngữ Trung
nó sẽ mở mang mình rất nhiều cái vì rất
nhiều tài liệu của Trung nó không hề
dịch ra tiếng Việt đâu à không phải dịch
ra tiếng Việt mà không hề dịch ra tiếng
Anh hay ngôn ngữ khác luôn ấy
đấy cũng như là
nhà sẽ mở thêm cho mình rất nhiều cái ví
dụ điển hình ngay từ việc mà tôi biết
tiếng Anh ấy tôi thấy là kiểu tôi đã xem
được rất nhiều cái gọi là video hay
những cái kiểu cái tôi không ngại xem
những cái diễn đàn hay theo dõi cái gì
đó không ngại đọc bình luận có rất nhiều
cái hay người ta sẽ viết nó người ta
viết bằng tiếng Anh thì mình cảm thấy ôi
mình mở mang thêm rất nhiều đ học các
thứ tôi tưởng mình thoáng hơn các thứ
các thứ bây giờ biết ngôn ngữ chung nữa
thì nó lại càng thêm một cái lợi thế nữa
Tải down in về mà
xem đấy Chẳng hạn đấy nên là tôi đang
nói cái này là không phải mỗi trong công
việc đúng không ạ Trong cuộc sống luôn
thay đổi tư duy thay đổi góc nhìn cuộc
sống rất là rõ luôn Nếu được thì mấy ông
càng mờ mang càng học hỏi trong khoảng
thời gian mà có thể học được thì càng
tốt ok trả lời được hết đúng ng rồi định
thật tôi cảm thấy là những cái buổi mà
mình có thể
ngồi thì
mà kiểu trả lời như này tôi tự công nhận
thôi đỉnh ạ Đấy rất biết cách trân trọng
bản thân Đúng rồi down lên đấy ngoài
việc để ngắm các bạn nữ thì đương nhiên
là mình sẽ nha nhỉ trên đấy chia sẻ rất
nhiều cái hay gọi là nó nó chia sẻ rất
nhiều cái gọi là có mang tí tích cực một
tí so với tiktok tiktok tôi cảm thấy là
bị thuật toán thì kiểu nó chia sẻ mấy
cái trên đấy nó không chất lượng bằng
trên dow in phát âm down in không biết
đúng hay sai
không chính xác chẳng có một cái bộ tài
liệu nào cả các bạn
à các bạn tiếp xúc nó đủ lâu và đấy Bây
giờ có ai ở hỗ trợ rồi copy cả câu đấy
vào để mà bảo nó giải thích lại thì mình
sẽ dễ hiểu hơn
chứ không có một tài liệu nào đâu và
thực ra là tôi gọi là có rất nhiều từ
tiếng Anh trên ảnh mà thực ra không thể
dịch được ấy mình cứ hiểu ná ná mình gặp
nó nhiều mình sẽ hiểu à Nó là gì Giống
như vừa nãy kiểu có từ trăn kết này hay
từ Index này đấy rất khó để mà dịch ra
dịch ra nó nghĩa là gì đấy Kiểu thế mình
phải chấp nhận việc là là gọ nhà chấp
nhận sự khác biệt à chấp nhận nó là một
cái gì đó kểu thấy mình gặp nhiều mình
sẽ quen
thôi đương nhiên là mình cũng phải hiểu
cái từ đấy gọi là hiểu một cách tương
đối là cái từ đấy để nói về cái điều gì
là được đừng cố dịch và cũng đừng nghĩ
là sẽ có một cái tài liệu gì đó mình dễ
học hơn không Mình gặp nhiều rồi mình sẽ
giú giờ cũng chưa chia sẻ
chia sẻ được này hôm trước là tôi ứng
dụng cái này vào trong cái phần bên công
ty tôi Ui tôi fix được rất nhiều rất
nhiều lỗi luôn nên là tôi kiểu phải chia
sẻ cho mấy ông đó là kiểu thằng lel nó
vừa tiện nên nó vừa dở dở đúng kiểu dở
khi mà cái này phải ra đời nó là kiểu
các bạn biết sck là gì không strick Là
kiểu nó kiểu chặt chẽ ấ nế Tôi dịch là
kiểu nó rang buộc chẽ các thứ thứ như
này chỉ kiểu cứ cho là kiểu khó cứng
cứng nhắc
à
thì cái thoạn này tốt COD để làm gì
Nghĩa em chỉ thằng RL nó đôi khi hỗ trợ
là kiểu các bạn gọi đến
gọi lazy loading này lazy loading là
kiểu dạng là khi bạn không khai báo khai
báo cái
relation không khai báo trước cái
vẫn load được ra nhưng nó sẽ bị kiểu Nếu
mà bạn mà load nó trong vòng lặp nó sẽ
bị lặp đi lặp lại khá nhiều lần rất là
bất lợi à Nó kiểu làm mình cứ truy vấn
đi truy vấn lại là một tiếp
theo cái này
Ừ những cái mà không khai báo trong cái
cái
viable mà bạn vẫn truyền vào thì nó sẽ
cảnh báo bạn này Vân Vân nhớ có cái
video ở đây để các bạn xem nhá đại khái
thì ờ tôi mở mấy cái này lên ở công ty
tôi u phát hiện ra kiểu nó ra một đống
bấc luôn một người sửa xong rất là tốt
đây đây có ví dụ này Ờ dưới này có ví dụ
này đây ví dụ bình thường Bạn lấy hết ra
này nhưng mà thực ra bạn gọi đến thêm cả
thằng user nữa thay vì bạn Load qut ở
trên này mà bạn dùng này nó sẽ bị một
vòng lặp là nó load nó load Cứ mỗi một
cái này nó lại load lại thằng này một
phát TH là là nó bị truy vấn lặp là n cộ
1 truy vấn nên là thành ng là nó rất là
tệ cái này sinh ra để chặn cái vụ đấy
này hoặc cái này cũng thế Như tôi vừa
bảo là bạn truyền một cái vào trong cái
thằng này bạn cứ nghĩ là Ừ cái này sẽ
được lưu lại nhưng không Cái này không
được truyền trong fiable của thằng Model
đấy nó sẽ báo lỗi à nó không báo lỗi nên
là cái nhưng mà nó bỏ cái này đi khỏi
thằng này thì cái này sinh ra đấy nó sẽ
thông báo cạch báo bạn này phải điền cái
này vào trong fiable của thằng này và
tiếp theo là đôi khi là mình sẽ thường
gọi kiểu dạng như này này là bình thường
nó sẽ không báo lỗi luôn nó chỉ trả về
cái này là nun nhưng mà nó rất là nguy
hiểm V rất nhiều lúc mà mình có thể gọi
V ra kiểu có thể là một là nó không hề
tồn tại cái thuộc tính này hai là mình
chưa hề select nó nhưng mà mình vẫn gọi
ra thì bây giờ nó sẽ có cảnh báo nên rất
là
tốt đấy đ đôi khi là gõ saze chính tải
như này Hôm trước tôi vừa gặp cái vụ này
xong có ông gõ saze chính tải như này
trên công ty tôi thật
đấy nên nên là kiểu không ai phát hiện
ra ấy Không ai phát hiện ra cái bgc đấy
cho khi kiểu mở cái stck này lên Nó kiểu
nó cảnh báo đỏ Lom ra trong đoạn code
thì mới kiểu Không phải đoạn code mà
trong clock ấy nên là mình phát hiện ra
mình sửa tốt nhên là nó thằng là fw ra
đời để tiện mấy cái bụ này thì giờ mình
phải phải tắt nó đi cho cho nó bất tiện
thì mình để mình làm việc đấy Kiểu thế
nhưng thực ra tôi mới chỉ mở được hai
cái này thôi và cái này Bọn tôi đang
chấp nhận là phải phải mở nó lên bởi vì
có một vài chỗ đúng là mình phải gọi lại
để load lại luôn dữ liệu ví dụ trong
trường hợp Ví dụ trong trường hợp này là
tôi chấp nhận gọi lại để load lại dữ
liệu mới các thứ các thứ có lý do nó cả
đấy ok không ạ ok
trước tôi có cái vụ này hôm tôi biết
được nó một cái BC mà BC khiến cho kiểu
công tôi đôi khi truy vấn Quá nhiều thứ
và trong và trong DB chẳng đềm gì cả ví
dụ một điển hình
nhá ví dụ một Điền hình Bây giờ tôi gửi
lên một cái
id id đấy chuỗi rỗng chẳng hạn nhưng mà
Mấy ông không hể validate cái cái cái ID
đấy mấy ông vẫn select ể trong DB như
thường đươ nhiên là ID nó là chỗi rỗng
nên nó nó sẽ thông báo là chẳng chả về
kết quả gì cả Được không ạ nhưng mà ý
tôi là mất thêm một cái chuy vấn vào
trong DB mọi cái thứ mà hiển nhiên là nó
sẽ sai đấy th chỉ là một ví dụ điển hình
thôi Hỏi
chấm cái kia không Hỏi chấm cái kia kia
là để em bị nhầm khái niệm rồi cái kia
là để
mà cái cái này là để mà em Em đang nói
cái vụ này đúng
không cái vụ revent này đúng không anh
đang nói là cái này là không phải cái
biến này không tồn tại Đương nhiên mình
sẽ phải hỏi chấm hỏi chấm kiểu kia là
anh em nói là cái thuộc tính này không
tồn tại cơ thì nó thằng lel không báo
lỗi và rõ ràng là thế là sai đúng không
ạ Sai cố Pháp hay gì gì đó Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ phải cảnh báo đấy thì cái vụ mà
Mấy ông phải luôn kiểm tra qua trước về
dữ liệu trước khi truy vấn và DB thì rõ
ràng là có những cái hiển nhiên là nó
sai vate rồi nhưng mà Mấy ông không hề
validate nên mấy ông gần như là dùng cái
DB để vi đết ấy nghĩa là truy vấn rõ
ràng những cái nó hiển nhiên nó không
tồn tại đấy đươ nhiên nó chẳng chả về
kết quả gì cả nhưng mà rõ ràng là mình
dùng thế không khác gì
dùng database và ides cả đúng không ạ
Mấy ông hiểu mấy ông hiểu ì tôi
không thì mình không có nên làm thế
không chắc chắn là không rồi mình không
thể kiểu tự nhiên là mình DB mình bị
kiểu truy vấn rất là nhiều mà rõ ràng
trong đó không ít đâu nhá trong đấy
không ít đâu đấy không phải trường hợp h
híu đâu nhá rất nhiều rất nhiều lúc là
kiểu người dùng kiểu người dùng kiểu
nhập bừa hay là không nhập gì đó nhập
sai nà thôi Mình vẫn truy vấn ch Gióng
DB để mình thông báo người dùng cái đấy
không tồn tại rõ ràng hiển nhiên mình có
thể làm va de đoạn đây đấy nên Nếu có
thể thì DB chỉ với tôi luôn quan điểm DB
là nơi lưu và lấy ra dữ liệu không hơn
không kém không xử lý gì đó trong DB cả
càng tốt xử lý hết mọi thứ trong code là
tốt nhất Nó tường minh nó minh bạch ai
nhìn vào có thể nhìn được và về sao sửa
nó rất là dễ đấy nên và code backend
sẽ làm là vate dữ liệu xong rồi xử lấy
dữ liệu ra trong DB rồi xử lý dữ liệu
đấy rồi trả về trong cho fen fen chỉ làm
tính năng hiển thị dữ liệu Thôi theo tôi
một quy chuẩn nó nên như thế không nên
kiểu vì tiết kiệm thời gian hay gì gì đó
mình nên mình xử lý ở fen hay là như thế
nào đó mình lại đi xử lý ở trong DB nó
bị kiểu theo tôi thì nó không không gọi
là nó sẽ khiến cho à chính cái người sau
người ấy muốn sửa cái đấy nó rất khó vân
vân nó không có sự đồng nhất thống nhất
ở công ty tôi thực ra thỉnh thoảng có bị
nhược điểm như thế đó là xử lý ở back em
một kiểu xử lý được fance một kiểu không
biết được kết quả hiển thị ra kiểu như
nào Không biết các bạn vờ bị dính kiểu
đấy chưa Nhưng mà nó không có một sự
thống nhất như thế làm cho không có cái
chuẩn nào đó ấy đấy đấy về xong bây giờ
mình về xong mình muốn sửa cái gì đó thì
mình sửa backend là chưa đủ mình lại
phải sang fend để sửa
đấy nên nếu có thể một vài cái biết đặc
biệt là đôi khi có vài thông tin nhạy
cảm thật mình sẽ phải để ở backend để xử
kiểu Hồi trước tôi chính tôi cũng hơi
lười và chính tôi kiểu gọi là muốn tiết
kiệm DB tôi thì tiết kiệm được bao nhiêu
không biết nhưng mà cứ cứ cho là muốn
tiết kiệm thêm một tí có thể nó chỉ là
trong bảng đôi khi là không có lưu nhiều
cột đầy đủ giống như thằng larel gợi ý
thực ra ít nhất là phải có created up
với updated up đúng không ạ thậ chỉ về
sau là deed up nhưng mà đôi khi về sau
các bạn còn thêm nhiều nữa thì đươ nhiên
là có một vài bảng thì thực ra nó không
cần quan trọng lắm nhưng mà đấy là các
bạn chưa biết được khi nó không quan
trọng thôi vì rõ ràng là có rất nhiều
lúc có rất nhiều lúc vì mình đôi khi
mình không lưu lại lại log không đi lại
lịch sử kiểu thao tác của của người dùng
ấy nên đã có rất nhiều lúc mà người dùng
làm cái thao tác gì đó mà tự nhiên code
của mình có một đoạn bấc Hồi đấy công ty
tôi có một đoạn bấc khiến cho kiểu toàn
bộ mấy cái kiểu product của một người nó
bị thay đổi chẳng ạn nhưng mình không hề
lưu lại cái
à Nói chung là nó không phải nằm ở trong
bảng produ mà trong trong bả bả product
của tôi bọn tôi thì có lưu cái trường
update update Ất rồi thì không sao nó
lại nằm ở trong một bảng khác nữa và
bảng đấy nó không hề lưu bất kỳ cái
cột thời gian nào cả nên nên thành ra là
nên thành ra là kiểu lúc mà mình phát
hiện được lỗi ví dụ lỗi Nó xảy ra từ từ
trong ngày hôm nay thôi chẳng hạn ông
không hề biết được những cái dữ liệu nào
nó đã bị kiểu sửa trong ngày hôm nay bởi
vì trong bảng đấy Thậm chí không có cột
ID nên là không cột ID để mà tự động
tăng ấy nên mình không hề nắm rõ được dữ
liệu nào nằm trước dữ liệu nào m không
hiểu Tôi không ạ Không hề biết được là
là mình phải rob mình phải backup như
thế
nên là một bài học xương máu như thế nữa
đó là bảng DB nó sinh ra để lưu dữ liệu
và về sau mình có thể cân nhắc việc là
mình xóa bớt các thứ thứ sau Nhưng mà
mình lưu thừa còn hơn thiếu có một sự
thật là như thế thường có một câu châm
ngôn tôi tôi nghe thế lưu thừa còn nơn
thiếu mình nên lưu những cái cột
mà nó liên ít nhất là liên quan đến thời
gian hay là mấy cái thứ khác được không
ạ Chứ không thì về sau là có cái bài
toán vấn đề gì đó xảy ra như thế mình
Lúc nãy mình xử lý như nào Đúng đúng
không ạ
Chịu thật sự
kiểu Tôi nhớ không lầm ở thằng fen hôm
trước tôi bị cái quả bấc đấy Làm tròn số
kiểu dị dị nhưng là nó không chỉ dừng ở
đấy đâu hôm trước là tôi Bọn tôi còn bị
khách hàng kiện một quả kiện thì nó hơi
bị quá nhưng nói chung là báo quả lỗi xô
cũng cũng kiểu âm kiểu dạng là người ta
cũng cắt ấy không đến nỗi kiểu cãi nhau
to nĩ như là người ta cũng cắt người ta
cũng khó chịu bởi
vì công thức hiển thị ở phá n một kiểu
back end thì xử lý một kiểu thành ra
công thức nó khác nhau công thức tính
toán liên quan đến tiền n mà liên quan
tiền on thì đương nhiên là mọi thứ phải
minh bạch rõ ràng đúng không ạ lệch lệch
một số lệch một số mà có lợi cho cho họ
thì chắc là họ không có ý kiến nhưng mà
lệch một số mà không có lợi cho họ Họ ý
kiến ngay đúng không ạ Và họ nghĩ rằng
kiểu mình nó sẽ liên quan đến tiền thì
người ta luôn kiểu bị bị
kiểu bị kỹ tính ấy bị kiểu dạng là nghĩ
rằng là có thể nó lừa mình thì sao ấy
hay là kiểu thậm chí là họ sẽ còn nghĩ
sâu xa hơn là có khi từ trước ấy nó lừa
mình hay kiểu thế nên thành ra chỉ cần
sai số một tí liên quan đến việc thống
kê liên quan tiền n ấy ui chết đấy Thế
nên thế nên tôi mới bảo là mọi thứ nên
xử lý ở một chỗ xong rồi xong rồi fanan
chỉ nên là làm hiển thị ra thôi Finance
mà còn liên quan đến việc tính toán rồi
Kiểu các thứ thứ thế khá là nguy hiểm
mấy ông hiểu mấy ông hiểu ý tôi không ạ
khách kiện được ấy khách kiện được
mà qu bên tôi chưa bị kiện n bên tôi
cũng không biết nói như nào đ khá không
đến nỗi là bị kiện nhưng mà chệt là nó
vẫn khá là nguy hiểm liên quan đến tiền
n đúng không ạ Nó chỉ đơn giản hiển thị
ra nó không hợp lý thôi nhá chứ không
Liên Quan Đế việc là mình ăn ăn bớt của
người dùng các thứ cũng đã như thế rồi
nhá Không biết là kiểu Nếu giả sử nó li
liên quan đến việc là tính toán gì gì đó
mà còn làm ảnh hưởng mất tiền của khách
hàng Ui V không biết th nó sẽ còn như
nào nữa đúng không ạ Đấy Tôi đi làm ở
công ty này tuy là vẫn chỉ dừng ở mức
một công ty chính thức ở B ngoài thôi
nhưng mà tôi đã được trải nghiệm khá
nhiều cái cũng gọi là khá khá nhiều bài
học thực tế các thời tử để tôi có thể
chia sẻ được cho mấy ông có thêm góp
nhìn các thứ thứ thế thế ổn đúng không ạ
Cũng không phải một con người chưa từng
trả chưa từng trải thì không có gì ở
khoe
ông về cái này đó là cái này à đây Cái
này để cái thư viện để mà hợp để mà
xong rồi sơ đồ các thứ thử thậm chí là
ra Phả
đây Cái này là tổ tiên này nếu dịch ra
này Đấy những cái cùng Dòng Máu này con
cháu này thứ thứ này Vân Vân bố mẹ này
đã khá thế xong rồi anh em họ dịch thô
như thế Thực ra cái này không phải dừng
ở mỗi việc là lấy
mỗi về áp dụng vào cho con người mà áp
dụng rất nhiều cái
ha Hay phết Nó còn kiểu nói chung là cái
này phù hợp việc là kiểu đa đa cấp ấy
theo như cấp độ ấy nói chung rất là
hay tôi cứ để lại link này cho mấy ông
xong ngồi à Thư A mấy cái link này tôi
có chia sẻ ở trong trên server discord
rồi Ừ thế có khi tí tôi xóa đi cũng được
để mấy ông có gì mấy ông vào đấy Ông mấy
ông
xem được không ạ Đấy còn về mỗi cái t gr
ảnh thì chắc là để hôm nào tôi có thời
gian thì tôi sẽ ngồi livestream code cho
mấy ông xem việc ngồi code làm
livestream để tôi định ngồi về
livestream co cái ảnh ở trên cái tumb h
trước của tôi à Cái trang gái xh gái xh
chọn ọc đấy gái xinh hả gái xinh xinh gì
đấy Tôi từng Truy cập trang web
đấy Cái này là tumbo ấy thì tôi sẽ kiểu
Khi nào tôi sẽ livestream để mà hướng
dẫn mấy ông ngồi CR ảnh từ trang này
chẳng hạn thì sẽ nên code như nào đấy th
nó có api hết mà CH đạn gọi api
được ok nhỉ Hôm nay cũng ngồi chém gió
hơn được tiếng rồi Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
lại ngồi nghỉ ngơi tí ngồi lại thư giãn
tí cũng hơi
căng
Nói chung là phải có thời gian nghỉ ngơi
dành thời gian bản thân các thứ thứ nữa
thì mới có thời gian để mà gồng để làm
việc được đúng không ạ gồng quá nó phá
sức quá nhở Ok không Mấy ông không hỏi
gì nữa thì chúng ta tạm dừng Đây nhá
Chào mấy ông nhá Bye